you will get tested and you will be
mandated and you'll have this digital
passport but that state that sounds
crazy that sounds like a Philip K dick
Total Recall Minority Report sort of
thing that can't be happening right now
I mean there can't be possible that
people would have to have QR codes on
their phones that are genetically
connected to them just so that they
could get on trains that couldn't be
happening in on planet Earth right now
China
yeah that's China That's China right now
so it's happening in front of our eyes
and the question is how many politicians
has China bought that are sitting in our
Halls of power right now well one of the
other interesting things related to
covid it's not just that they wanted a
digital ID and maybe they can just shut
down your bank accounts if you say
something mean about about the elderly
man pretending to be president or
whatever it might be but it is coming
out that myocarditis is a problem and a
lot of people warned of it that there
were heart problems related to these
vaccines here's NBC News a little late
but okay myocarditis after coveted
vaccination Pfizer and moderna are
tracking adverse health effects if any
that may appear in the Years following a
diagnosis of vaccine Associated heart
problems you guys may remember that our
Surgeon General here in Florida Joseph
latipo a few weeks ago posted a research
paper about
myocarditis and young men and how it's
up something like if you don't have to
quote me exactly I think it was
something like 800 percent Twitter
censored him and took it down then they
said it was a mistake all the usual
stuff